this is the person with the highest
bouncing all of One Piece and it's
someone no one would have expected
Swampy's manga has recently revealed a
ton of new bounties that top anything
we've seen ever before now Bounty tell
us who are the strongest and most
dangerous people on the planet the
highest Bounty must be someone with such
crazy power and influence that the world
government is more desperate to catch
them than anyone else now Oda really
Dropped a Bomb when he revealed Luffy's
new ridiculous Bounty of 3 billion
berries catapulting into the top 10
bounties of all time with this type of
money you could actually buy 10 giant
new ships in the one piece world but
it's not him nor is it his mentor Shanks
who has the highest Bounty of any active
pirate right now with over 4 billion
berries and it's not even the pirate
king himself Goldie Roger with 5.5
billion berries instead the first place
Daisy Luffy's family his father monkey
the dragon who is supreme commander of
the Revolutionary Army and is Waging War
against the celestial dragons who is
known as the most wanted criminal in the
world which must mean that